on va le voir des opérations sont menées
conjointement la police bavaroise et des
autorités autrichiennes
les patients vont très vite leur
parcours leur objectif n'est pas de
faire passer la frontière à leur
clientèle ne bouge pas et que la bosnie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pendant deux ans ici ensemble âge une
petite devinette quand vous allez jouer
si vous prenez been sport que vous
enlevez les droits des matches de
champions league les plateaux tout neuf
et pires comme consultant qu'est-ce qui
reste très belle équipe 21
tout simplement j'ai envoyé hier soir le
reporter au parc des princes couvrir le
match du psg et qui dit match des
supporters on nous dit supporters eux
louent ses profits du
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tiny match les supporters relou tu
profites de la caméra pour faire les
dédicaces à la terre entière il a pas
oublié un de ses potes c'est pas
possible